we are on problem number 11. i i wrote
out the chart although you probably
can't read it so they say according to
the table above
car engine oil with a rating of 5w
5w
flows how many times as fast as a car
engine oil with a rating of 20 w so how
much faster is 5w versus 20w
and so let's read the chart
we say
it says 10w is half as fast as 5w right
so 5w is twice as fast as 10w
so 5w
is 2 times 10w right
then they tell us that 15w is half as
fast as 10w
right
so 10 w is double the speed of 15 w
actually let's do it that way 10 w is
double the speed of 15 w right
and then 15 w is double the speed of 20
w
right so you have two doublings so 10 w
is going to be four times as fast right
it's two times as fast as this which is
two times as fast as this so 10 w is
four times faster than 20 w
so 10 w is four times 20 w
right
10 w 20 is 4 times 20 w and 5 w is twice
10 w so 5 w
is going to be 8 times 20 w
and really the most confusing thing
about this is the fact that these labels
for these ratings involve numbers that
aren't proportional to actually how much
faster they are than each other i mean
you could actually change this to you
know x
y you know y
z
and then it might be a little bit easier
but that's all there is to it this is
twice as fast as this which is twice as
fast as this and if you wrote 5w up here
so 5w is twice as fast as this which is
twice as fast as this which is twice as
fast as that so you're doubling three
times so it's eight times as fast and
that's choice c
next problem
let me draw that
we have a line like that and then
a straight line at the bottom
like that and then they have a line
look something like that
this is
p
a
q
b
r this is line m this is line l
figure not drawn the scale sure
and the figure above points p a and b p
a and b are equally spaced on line l
equally spaced so that means the
distance from p to a is equal to the
distance from a to b they're equally
spaced that's good to know
and points p q and r equally spaced on
line m
okay
so p q and r equally space and well it
didn't look like it the way i drew it
but so this
is equal to this
equal space of line m if p be
pb is equal to four
so that entire thing is equal to four
that equals 4. so we immediately know
that this is 2 and this is 2 right
because they're equally spaced so that
entire thing is 4. pr is equal to 6.
so
this entire thing is equal to 6.
so we know that this is 3
and this is three
and a q is four aq
aq
is four
what is the perimeter of quadrilateral
r q a b r let's see where's q q
a
b
r so we know this side we know this side
we know this side we just have to figure
out we just have to figure out this side
i'll tell you right now that this is
going to be a similar triangle problem i
believe right because there's no
right because these triangles are going
to be proportional to each other how do
i know that well we have
so if you look at
look at i'm going to draw two triangles
for you you have this big triangle
you have that big triangle
and then you have
the smaller triangle
this one i won't use a line and then you
have the smaller triangle right here
and the big triangle is similar to the
smaller triangle and how do i know that
well they share an angle here
and we know that
we know that
the bigger triangle
two of its sides are just double the the
sides of the other
uh two angles
sorry we know that we know that for
example this side of the big triangle
is double this side on the small
triangle right
similarly we know this big side of the
big triangle
is double this side on the small
triangle
so two sides are proportional to each
other we have one common angle we know
that this is a similar triangle
so we know that this side is going to be
double this side so this side is going
to be eight
right and you could probably guess that
even if you didn't want to prove that
they're similar triangles so this is
eight the perimeter that we had to
figure out to begin with this is the
quadrilateral right here
is going to be eight
plus three
plus four
plus 2
and what is that that's 8 plus 17 right
9 right 17 and that is choice e
next problem
e
problem 13.
okay 13 and 14 refer to these functions
so
g of n
is equal to n squared
plus n
and h of n is equal to n squared minus n
so the first problem they want to know
what g of 5
minus h of 4 is
so g of 5 let's let's stick in 5 into g
right so you get 5 squared
plus 5 i just replace 5 where n is
and then we're going to subtract h of n
so what's h of n
oh sorry h of 4 i look like a an h of
four
so h of four is four squared
minus four
right and so let's simplify this as 25
plus five
minus 16 plus four
so that's what 30
minus 16 plus 4
right
so 30 minus 16
is
30 minus 16 is 14 plus 4 is 18.
so that is choice d
all right problem 14 also applies to
this so do it right here which of the
following is equivalent to
h of m plus one
h of m
plus 1.
so we essentially just everywhere we see
an n here we put an m plus 1
right so h of m plus 1 is equal to we
see an n so we put an n plus 1 there
m plus 1
squared
minus instead of an n n plus one
multiply that out you get m squared plus
two m
plus one
and then minus m
minus one
let's see so
this one and this one cancel out
and then you are and then two m minus m
so you're left with
m squared
minus
m
m squared minus m so h of m plus one
h of n plus 1 is equal to m squared
minus m
but isn't that the same thing as h of m
reminds me of that store
that's agent i'm not h of m although
that would be a fun name for a store as
well
h of m well what's h of m you put an m
where you see an n so that also equals m
squared minus m
so the answer is h of m and let me now
look at the choices
and that is not there
so i have
made a mistake i have made a mistake
m squared plus
1 squared right they're saying which of
the following is equal to h of m let me
let me do it clear things okay
so they say which of the following is
equivalent to h of m
plus one
h of m
and that is equal to
h of m right right that is equal to
m plus one squared
minus
m plus one
that's m squared
plus two m
plus one
minus m minus 1.
so that's m squared
plus m oh sorry plus m m squared plus m
and then this cancels out right
so h of m
plus 1 is equal to m squared
plus m
right and what's m squared plus m well
that's the same thing as g of m
because take take g of n or take g of m
and that's also m squared plus m
so that is choice a
before i cleared it my mistake was when
i did two m minus m i got for some silly
reason minus m instead of positive m
should be a positive m that was my
mistake i'll see you in the next video